and the winner of the john cassavetes
award is shiva baby
[Applause]
shiver baby is based on emma seligman's
nyu thesis short film of the same name
the film's total budget was just about
200 000
shiva baby has a record-breaking 16-week
continuous run at the famed quad cinema
in new york city
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much
uh thank you so much to film independent
for this incredible honor we made this
movie almost three years ago in a very
hot sweaty house and there were some
amazing people in that house who made
this happen so
thank you to katie karen and lizzy our
amazing producers for
running that house
and for creating such beautiful
organized chaos within it
thank you so much to our dp maria rushi
who gave me like a year for life to
figure out what this movie was going to
look like um thank you to hannah parker
editor for many many sleepless nights um
our incredible composer aerial marks
gave me the panic attack and my dreams
thank you um to our amazing cast thank
you so much for trusting me and for
being patient and for not being divas
and dealing with the sweat and the
mosquitoes and everything else
thank you so much to all of our
associate and executive producers for
supporting us
thank you to south by southwest for this
is based off a short film and thank you
for giving us the platform that you did
four years ago
this is also this is based off like a
college short so i want to thank our
professor yamana demisi who helped shape
the story with us um
we want to take a second to dedicate
this to um two people who helped make
this movie who are no longer with us one
of our executive producers elliot wally
and one of our actors sandra james we
miss you very much oliver shalom thank
you for everything you gave us and
lastly i want to thank the incredible
rachel senate behind me
[Applause]
she's an incredible incredible uh force
of nature and
thank you for giving me the ambition and
motivation and inspiration to
make this movie and being my emotional
support system
that you need in order to withstand
making a movie that qualifies for this
award
i'm so lucky i get to work with my best
friend and i love you so much
thank you so much have a great night